[Music]
germany and at least two hundred years
around germany for at least 200
years if not longer and
thus the decisive challenge
for political leadership
i would actually say
germany is looking for a constructive relationship with
great britain believes
nobody else in europe is
german national
we are like a volcano from the
general
and that is exactly what we have experienced in recent
years the europeans in europe
their superiority a sense of
superiority the germans are
morally on the better side
to grasp with hands was constant
keeping the european institutions together
she has  on the one hand
has contributed to the fact that the break